pay attention to the experienced one of
the things I'm constantly trying to
drive home in my businesses is paying
attention to the experience for the
customers it's really important that the
customer has a great experience in
dealing with your company not just the
benefit that they get from buying your
product or service and consuming your
content or whatever your business model
is so as an example I look at Toronto
day and salsa we just we don't just
teach people how to dance salsa we
improve their confidence you look at
students coming in here and the first
day they're super shy and they're
staying in the corner and I'll talk to
anybody and within a couple weeks
they're more confident in their dancing
abilities they're more confident in
themselves that search that have a
ripple effect often to the rest of their
life they're taking care of themselves
better their dressing sexier now they
have more friends or talking to people
more it's a it's a massive life change
that happens for so many are students
and even though they're coming just to
learn dance moves we give them a lot
more the experience matters what happens
in the class matters the first thing
that I did when I took over this studio
was I changed up the lights I you know
put family on the wall I made a tree
like the experience matters to me when
you walk in the studio what things look
like how people are treated and how
people are dealt with matters a lot and
it's not just about the private servers
are barring so how this relates to my
book this is the book video is I'm
working on my bonus page now and the
bonus page is about bulk orders so if
you buy one book you get the book but if
you buy different quantities of books
then you get additional bonuses for
savills you who want to support me more
and be more involved get more access
then you can buy those extra features
and what I'm trying to do is make that
page something interesting and exciting
in the positive experience and simplify
things so that there's not a thousand
different book packages that don't make
sense but you know five or six that you
can pick from and the names of those
packages mean something to me and what's
in those packages mean something to me
and I want that entire experience of
hitting that pay
age and finding the packages right for
you to be hopefully a pleasurable one it
doesn't mean we're always going to hit
the mark but that's the intent going in
it's not just saying here it is take it
or leave it and you're getting a good
book at the same time right like the
experience matters the experience
matters for me on the YouTube videos
right when we think about the intros in
the content and why I'm spending why I
still review all the videos that go out
you know I want it to be good I want to
be proud of it i want it to be something
that when you see it you like it you
appreciate it it sparked something that
makes you want to change something in
your life or change your mindset around
something that that's a big
responsibility for me knowing that you
guys put so much value on these videos
you know i want to make sure that i can
give as much as i can to you and again
it doesn't mean that we always hit the
mark we make mistakes we try new things
they don't always work but the intention
is always positive the intention is
always you create a great experience and
so I hope you can take that to your
business too what's the experience of
dealing with you beyond just the product
or service that they're buying that
entire process of talking to you
visiting your website you know dealing
with the content that you put up what
happens after the sale are you following
up are you checking in on them are you
going the extra mile I trying to help
them beyond just what they bought from
you help them achieve a greater goal
whatever that is if you can provide that
good experience you'll feel better
because you're giving back and you're
helping somebody out which just feels
good but it's also going to help your
business significantly as well let's get
to the questions so first up is Natalie
who wrote in the say we are here to win
and we must help each other when to when
your book would be read and supported by
the masses even those beyond your
youtube channel thank you natalie really
appreciate that support that was the
goal and say you know give me more
context and just i know there wasn't a
question here but to try to provide
value to you guys my goal is to help a
billion entrepreneurs and that was one
of my reasons for going to do a book and
going with a major publisher I didn't
have a massive need to write a book
there's a lot of ways that I could have
a reach and impact and I didn't want to
do it self publishing because I felt
like I wouldn't get it in the hanes as
many people I can make more money doing
it one hundred percent you make way more
money sell publishing then going with a
traditional publisher but I'm not driven
by money it's not the goal
all I want to have an impact and so
that's why I went with the major
publisher and so yes that is my a my
intention my goal is to be able to not
just give it to you guys who are on my
youtube channel but to reach a new
audience who may not be on YouTube as
much or may not have ever heard of me
but that can help through traditional PR
and through my publisher and through
bookstores to spread the message to how
people believe right we've got to help
more people believe in what they're
doing believe in themselves believe that
it's going to work out and so that was
the thought process behind going with a
major publisher another question from
Natalie came in is it possible make a
simple children's book like 20 pages for
children so they begin to plan their
lives around being a business owner that
is super interesting super important I
love being able to give back and help in
the education space I don't believe we
introduced it earlier enough in
education I know that a lot of my videos
are being used in schools in high school
and university level I don't know how
early it's being used people as part of
their curriculum the teachers introduced
watching one of the top 10 videos or one
of the interesting videos on a regular
basis to try to inspire the students
it's happening much more on a teacher
level rather than a school level or a
district level or board level and it's
something that I'm really interested in
I'm not actively pursuing it but
whenever i do get reached out to by
teachers i try to help out as much as i
can like do you want to do a hangout you
want to do webinar can I be a resource
for the kids it's something I'm
passionate about and I can see myself
getting more into it's not a burning
thing that I have to take care of right
now but as those opportunities come up I
would look for look for me to play a
bigger role in education space whether
it's in the form of a book for kids or
videos or something totally different
speaking engagements whatever it is it's
on my radar and I appreciate you
bringing it up next up with shafiq hope
I pronounced that okay Evan I love you
thank you bro your content is awesome
your aim is noble but it's a fan I feel
obligated to tell you that you're
pumping up too much new content too
quickly I try to watch all your stuff
you upload what I'm having a hard time
keeping up now so first of all I really
appreciate the love I appreciate the
feedback I love it when you guys try to
give me suggestions on what to do
you here's the thing I don't see myself
as a show it's channel and I've talked
about this number of times on the
channel my aim is to produce a lot of
content that can help you grow my aim is
not just to produce one video a week my
aim is to provide lots of different
content where you can learn from all the
successful people and I don't need you
to watch every video if you see a video
on my channel that doesn't interest you
that you don't like the topic you don't
you know that place right now where you
need to learn that that's totally cool
just like you don't turn on CNN or you
know CNBC or HGTV or whatever a
television station and expect to watch
every single episode of every single
show that they air right I think too
many people are restricted in their view
I also want to make sure that you take
an action like I would much rather you
watch one video a week and take action
and go improve your life and make a big
change then sit there in front of
YouTube all day long right that's not my
goal so have you just watching videos
all day long I need you to go and do
something that's what drives me at the
same time I don't know that people
invest enough in themselves the content
that I'm putting out especially you look
at the top 10 series in the believe life
series in the mentor me series we're
spending time to go through hours and
hours and hours of footage to find the
very best you look at an Elon Musk top
10 video as an example how many
interviews has he done how many speeches
has he done how many videos are there
out there of him we take all of that
condense it into one video for you that
maybe 10 minutes maybe 15 minutes maybe
20 minutes maybe 25 minutes the best
that he's ever said on camera we combine
and put together for you that's an
insane opportunity that's what i wanted
for me selfishly is why i wanted to
share it with you guys and thankfully
you enjoy you're consuming it too and
sharing it and since you really
appreciate that but if you are not the
time to to watch that and digest it and
learn from these successful
entrepreneurs honestly I feel like you
need to make the time like the
leadership people on my team I make them
watch the top 10 vid
goes every day every morning it's part
of the process I need you to be exposed
to greater things because if all you're
doing is the day to day stuff and you
never expose to the things that can make
you go bigger then you're never going to
grow then all the creativity and all the
big ideas are only going to come from me
and I don't want that I need you to grow
as a human beat and you don't get enough
of that from the people in your life and
so that's why I create these videos to
push you and challenge you so one if you
don't have the time cool you know I
don't need you to watch every video most
important for me is that you are
watching videos in your in your having
an impact you're changing something at
the same time though I'm not asking for
a lot like what's the total amount of
time of all the videos that I put up on
a daily basis 30 minutes 40 minutes like
how much time you spend in watching TV
you spend 30 40 minutes watching TV a
day what are the other activities that
you're doing I would say that watching
my videos for 30 or 40 minutes a day
it's a single most most impactful thing
in terms of resource you could inject in
your head period that exists period and
if you don't want to make that
investment in yourself that's on you so
I have no intention of slowing down I
have no intention of going to one video
a day or one video a week or a couple of
times a week if you can't keep up
totally cool to really appreciate that I
appreciate your viewership alone with
you for the videos that you do watch and
I hope you take action but I'm a channel
I'm not a show and everything that I put
out is quality and can change your life
that's why I do it so hopefully that
explains it next up is Shelly Marie
looking forward to your book you've got
me thinking about learning salsa Thank
You Shelly appreciate the support and
love and yes part of my selfish drive i
guess for why I do the videos here at
Toronto dance salsa is one it it you
know it's easy i got of space that's
convenient that can store my light and
gear and it's easy to access and get to
but also give some exposure for the
business right i think what you have to
figure out is what what is the asset
that you can bring to your company what
can you
reach the most I've had success on
YouTube and as an entrepreneur and I can
bring some of that status to help the
businesses that I grow and my
longer-term vision is actually to invest
in five to ten companies that are in
around my area yonge and sheppard and
city here in Toronto with people who
want to grow who want to learn who want
to do something way bigger who want to
make money but more importantly want to
have a big impact and where I can bring
contribution and I can bring some of my
network and status to help that company
grow and raise their awareness so that's
why I'm doing its part of my youtube
channel for those of you who've watched
more the history you may remember the
believe wall behind me or is filling out
of my office yeah so I'm glad you're
feeling the salsa and I'm looking
forward to creating more content on the
tds youtube channel too so stay tuned
for that Pavel writing in you are my
favorite dude on here Thanks pavo
feeling the love it's always humbling
when people say that I'm one of their
favorite youtubers or I have one of
their you know their favorite YouTube
channels I believe for me I love my
youtube channel the most like if you
take away my knowledge my advice the
things that I talk about just the wisdom
from the famous entrepreneurs and all
the expertise that they bring I feel
like everybody in the world should be
watching the videos i feel like if
everybody watched the videos just the
top 10 series every day if that's what
people did everybody in the world I feel
like the world would be a much better
place I feel like we'd have a lot more
understanding I feel like people would
believe in themselves to have more
confidence I feel like people would be
jumping on opportunities to live the
best version of their life I see the
transformational change as having a lot
of you guys and your writing in the
comments and how it serves as daily
motivation inspiration for you I see the
direct impact on me I see the impact it
has on the people around me like locally
on my team who are make watch the videos
on a daily basis I genuinely feel and I
feel that as a responsibility to to
create great content for you guys that
if everybody in the world was watching
this channel the world would be a much
better place to live koel pre yasha
eager to read your book
I'm so eager for you guys to read the
book it's been so long I know it's tetta
every week I'm super excited we're
almost there Mark Alaimo gets to begin
soon and the stuff that is the exercise
that people have gone through by reading
the book and the transformational change
at its hat on people's lives not just
their business but their lives is so
exciting and I can't wait for it to be
out there I can't wait for it to to be
in your hand to see the impact to see
the emails coming back and to see the
the growth that comes in the businesses
and the impact that that has on the
greater community on this planet I'm so
excited I'm so eager it's what keeps me
going through all of these weeks and
weeks and weeks and weeks and and I'm
excited to like join you in that process
to expose it to you how it goes about
creating a book in the marketing part of
a tube so coming up soon next up Paul
Thompson will this book Beyond audible
so the book will definitely be in audio
version I don't know about the
distribution yet but as soon as we have
kind of data on how it's going to be
released in audio version I will let you
guys know next up alum al beauty yeah he
mentioned me in the video believe nation
rocks I agree believe nation does rock
and it also shows you guys the impact of
just giving somebody recognition right
like I make these videos for you guys to
answer your questions to help you out
but also you could apply to your
business giving a shadow to a customer
on your blog on twitter on facebook on
youtube like people like to be
appreciated if you'll recognize
especially when it's not expected and so
finding ways consistently like i would
have that as part of your weekly task
because find a way to surprise somebody
make somebody feel warm and recognized
in your personal life too right like do
you recognize your husband or wife or an
up do you recognize your kids enough do
you say thank you to your parents enough
right like a little bit of recognition
when people don't expect it can really
go a long way to making people feel good
about themselves it's a great strategy
for your business and for your life but
it also just feels good it's like the
right thing to do so show a little more
recognition to the people in your life
next up grand apparel hi Evan hi and
last up from J reyez the auto by happy
face I am super interested to figure out
how many of you guys would just auto by
the book because of me because you think
it's going to be good like if you guys
are thinking about it and I know there's
some people that I would just buy their
book I don't even know what the book
would be because I really like that
person I feel like it would contribute
to my life and I think it shows the
loyalty and I wonder for your own
business how many of your customers are
so loyal to your company to what you do
to you as a human being to your business
that they would consider buying
something from you even if they didn't
know what it was like I'm going to write
a book and they're going to buy it from
you even they don't know the topic how
many people would do that that really
shows how much emotional connection you
have to your customers and if not if the
answer is not a lot of people then you
need to do a better job of connecting
with them creating content of telling
stories of going deeper being personal
showing yourself so it's not just all
business because you don't want it to
just be about dollars and cents all the
time you want to create loyalty you want
to create that emotional connection
because it ties people to you wait
longer generates referrals generates
word-of-mouth generates more business
has them buying for you for a lot longer
so again another great business strategy
but also it's a good thing to do like it
makes you feel happy it fills your soul
to be able to connect to your customers
so that's it for this week thank you
guys for joining I'd love to know what
you think about the topic which is about
creating a great experience for your
customers or if you have a question for
my book or the book writing process
leave it in the comments below and I
will try to answer you on next week's
video I also really appreciate all the
advice and suggestions you guys had for
what you want to include in the bonuses
that i'm giving away for bulk orders so
i'm going to incorporate some of those
ideas if you have more leaving below
again i really appreciate you guys
watching thank you for your support
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon